مشاهدينا الكرام نرحبوا بضيفتنا هنا في
استوديو التغطيه في مقر ااا اعمال ااا
منتدى دافوس الاقتصاديه العالمي بنائبه
رئيس الوزراء وزيره الخارجيه سلوفينيه
الثانيه فيون سيده فيون مرحبا بك كنتي مما
نقترحوا ان شاء محكمه خاصه لملاحقه
مرتكبيه الاعمال الوحشيه في اوكرانيا الى
اي الى اين وصل هذا الاقتراعه ما مدى
واقعيته
شكرا
[موسيقى]
المصريون عن ارتكاب الفضاء
لا ينال جزائهم لن نواجه مصالحه حقيقيه
لهذا السبب علينا ان نفعل كل المسؤولين
امام
العداله والنظمه حمايه القانون الدولي
ونحميه النظام الدولي وايضا الصوره الجيو
سياسيه تغيرت بشكل كبير نحن كم
نبقى اقوياء سويه
يقودنا هذا الى السؤال عن واقعيه هذا
الاقتراح روسيا لم تنهزم بعد كيف يمكن جلب
من تعتقدون انه ارتكبوا جرائم حرب خلال
هذه الحرب الاخيره وروسيا لم تنهزم وهي
دوله قويه تستطيع حمايه مواطنيها وقدتها
العسكر وقدتها العسكري
حقيقي
المدنيون الاطفال الابرياء الذين يموتون
الذين لا مستقبل لهم في بلادهم عندما
نتذكر ذلك علينا نعرف من كان المسؤول ذلك
بشكل غير قانوني ولا نسمعها بقتل المدنيين
وبتدمير
التحتيهم من اجل حمايته اراضيهم سلامه
بلادهم لهذا السبب نريد ان نرى في نفس
الوقت
الصواريخ التي
الصفاوض البحث عن
حلول سلميه قد يبدو هذا مبالغا فيه وقد
يكون صعبا متخيله نحن نرى القصر يستمر
يوميا في هذه المناسبه اود ان نعرب عن
تعازيه اللي تحطم المريخيه التي لاقى فيها
وزير الداخليه حتفه لا حرب يمكن ان يكون
فيها رابعون
النقطه الاخرى ايضا كنتي من من دعموا
ودعموا الى تقليل اعتماد القاره الاوروبيه
على امدادات الطاقه القادمه من روسيا هذا
الامر ايضا له تبعات خطيره قفز باسعار
الغاز واسعار همم الطاقه والمواد
الاحفوريه الى مستويات قياسيه ادخلت
العالم كله وليس ادخلت العالم كله وليس
القاره الاوروبيه فقط في نفق لا تبدو له
نهايه واثر ذلك على يعني كانت ارتداداته
امتدت الى كثير من القطاعات حتى القطاع
الزراعي صناعه الاسمده المواد
البتروكيماويه وما الى ذلك هل كان هذا
مساله تقليل الاعتماد على الغاز الروسي او
الانتدابات الطاقه الروسيه كان هذا طرحا
واقعيا
اه يا نوده
[موسيقى]
مصادر الطاقه
في اوروبا في الطاقه ونحن طالبنا باوروبا
قويه وموحده وهذا
مهم ليس من خلال فرض العقوبات على النظام
الروسي ولكن ايضا من خلاله البحث عن مصادر
بديله للطاقه وبحث عن شركاء جدد وربما من
خلال خطط اكثر طموحا في مجال وسائل الطاقه
مياه نقيه وغير ذلك هذا ما ينبغي ان نفعله
اتيت على ذكر الحرب المروعه التي شهدها او
شهيده منطقه غرب البلقان حسنا الان
البلقان ايضا ليست على ما يرام هناك
التوتر حاد بين صربيا وكوسوفو ولكن انقسام
ايضا احيانا الموقف من اوكرانيا والحرب
الروسيه فيها بعض البلدان مثل صربيا مثل
المجر تدعم الجانب الروسي في مقابل بعض
البلدان الاخرى التي تدعم الجانب
الاوكراني وتقف من خلفه همم كيف تقيمين
الوضع وموقف بلادكم مما يحدث في البلقاء
في محيطكم
سكين
جوله في غرب البلقان كنت في كوسوفو وجبل
الاسود منطقه
عدم الاستقرار السياسيه
غرب البلقان هي جزء منها
الاتحاد
وايضا نحن
ايضا تزايد التوتر
الروسي الذي والوجود الروسي الذي يمكن ان
يشكل الخطا لهذا السبب نحن في حاله حوار
مع الاوروبيين وخاصه مع الشباب في اوروبا
اوروبا
وانا ادعمه بقوه النجمه البلدان السويه
القريبه من بلادنا في غرب البلقان التي
تشاركنا قيمنا في احترام حقوق الانسان
وايضا ايجاد بيئه مناسبه من اجل خلق حياه
افضل للمواطنين
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام